House Speaker Nancy Pelosi is opening up
about her first three months at the top
of the democratic-led House of
Representatives on Sunday 60 minutes
Speaker Pelosi is the first woman to
hold the Speaker position and she is the
first person since 1955 to regain the
gavel after losing it a lot of firsts
for Nancy Pelosi as Speaker she is one
of Washington's most powerful people
Pelosi spoke to Leslie Stahl about the
perception that she is a thorn in the
side of her Republican colleagues and a
thorn in the side of President Trump one
of the complaints we've heard is that
you don't reach across the aisle it
seems like right now nothing is getting
done you pass things whatever it is dies
in the Senate we hadn't died together
a hundred days the fact that we even
passed them in the house is a victory
let's figure out the places the figure
out where we can find common ground
there's always been bipartisan support
for dreamers bipartisan support for gun
safety bipartisan support for
infrastructure but why doesn't anything
get done we just started we just started
with three months since we were in
office but you're talking about a
hundred days this president's been in
office for two years plus and we've been
here three months hey may I introduce
you to the idea of the power of the
speaker is to set the agenda we didn't
have a speaker who would bring a gun
bill to the floor we didn't have a
speaker who would bring a dreamers issue
to the floor we do now and that's a very
big difference that power of the speaker
is awesome awesome she was making a
point there lesley stahl joining us at
the table you know there were many
people thought you know her time is done
maybe it's time for new blood young
blood she has certainly shut all of that
down she did and you know what strangely
President Trump was the one who gave her
that opportunity because remember that
meeting in the Oval Office major I'm
sure you do yes and she stood up to him
and walked out in that orange coat and
her image was changed on a dime with the
public I think they knew how tough she
was in the Congress but this was a
moment
that was transforming and her part about
the power is about setting an agenda
that is different than the agenda in the
first two years of the Trump
administration and you can't get
everything done but you can raise new
questions and force the opposition party
in this case Republicans to at least
have to respond at some level which is a
predicate for the conversation we're
gonna have in 2020 she's tough but she
also is running at one of the
legislative bodies now she is the
speaker which of the house but she
thinks of Congress she acts that way so
when you say a different agenda it's a
stronger agenda because she has the
power now as she says being Speaker is
awesome I can really put these things on
the table and you know something she is
a very strong person and stronger than I
think we realized the pot I mean we the
public how so well because she look just
watch how she stood up to me in this
interview whatever I asked I was just
swatted squatted down in a nice way
that's the other thing about her she's
both powerful and she's very feminine
she dresses like a girl like a woman and
she in a way wants to show everybody
that you can be steely tough and
feminine and there's no contradiction
there they're the same thing and she's
going to show you and there's also a
sense I get that in the second time
around she views the job and her role
differently and in a place of strong of
more strength than she did the first
time there's no question she she says
that she sees herself as equal to the
president because the legislative branch
and the executive branch are co-equal
we're a fractured country at the moment
fractured in Congress the Republicans
control one chamber she is leading the
other but her party as well also has
divisions what did she say about healing
those well she she says we're unified
what she says even as they're nipping
the the left is nipping at her she
brought in 43 new Democrats from
Republican districts and she know she
has
to hold them she can't allow those
districts to flip back and they're more
centrist or more conservative whatever
and so she needs to bring the left the
far left the Socialists in her caucus
she needs to make sure that they don't
jeopardize those acknowledge there are
socialists in her caucus she might take
issue he said she said five yeah five
she's a number well there's progress
it's confusing yeah there really are
only two or three socialists yeah and
then there are progressives and there
are much larger faction and when you
speak of the larger left liberals there
as a larger group but really trying to
change her agenda a little bit I know
Leslie we got to go but do you think
even the president is a little
intimidated by her he does not have a
nickname for her other than Nancy not
are we coming back yeah yeah yeah it's
it's very interesting I think that
dynamic you're interesting backs are two
of them but I'll tell you something
really fun fact guess who did give her a
nickname george w bush right and you
know what the nickname was i do because
she's third in line leslie says it's
ladies and gentleman let's just say that
thank you very much and you can see much
more of less lee's interview with
speaker Pelosi this sunday on 60 minutes